sylvia beau gary merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france alors
dites-nous 45 villes portugaises sous
couvre-feu nocturne est ce que vous
attendiez personnellement à de telles
mesures
ah oui tout à fait parce que variante
ici augmenté et les veaux à mouthe
beaucoup depuis quelques semaines déjà
et les hospitalisations elles ne
montrent pas autant qu'auparavant
au mois de février au mois de mars
c'était terrible parce qu'on n'avait pas
encore une aussi grande portion de la
population vaccinée
maintenant il ya moins
d'hospitalisations il ya moins de quatre
graves mais quand même il ya des
hospitalisations il ya des personnes aux
soins intensifs donc c'était tout à fait
il fallait s'y attendre
et est-ce qu'on portugais n'en
précisément à lisbonne où vous êtes est
ce que la population respecte les gestes
barrière où vous constatez peut-être un
petit peu de relâchement
les gens sont fatigués il ya ce qu'on
appelle la fatigue pandémique et les
gens sont fatigués c'est vrai moi je ne
vais pas tellement à lisbonne je vais
pas dans les grandes villes un petit une
petite vie des alentours de lisbonne je
trouve que les gens sont quand même
j'espère que dd skimming qu'on leur
donne et au niveau de la vaccination on
a vu que plus de 50 % de la population
aux portugaises avaient déjà fait sa
première injection il ya un peu plus de
30% de portugais qu'on les deux
injections
est ce que les autorités
on fait comprendre que si la vaccination
augmenter et bien le couvre feu sera
élevé non pas du tout la vaccination
progresse très bien au portugal
moi même j'ai déjà les deux doses de
vaccin
je suis entièrement vacciner j'ai mon
certificat maintenance avancée par
tranche d'âge
ils vont attaquer à partir de 35 ans je
crois il envoie les visages de 2 à près
de baisser et peut-être les adolescents
ou celui plus tard c'est envisagé
d'évacuer aussi il ya des pays où le
gouvernement est très critiqué sur sa
façon de gérer la crise sanitaire en
france par exemple c'est le cas est-ce
que ça l'est au portugal où est ce que
la population a confiance on sait
décideurs politiques et la confiance
baisse parce que les signaux sont
souvent contradictoires et souvent les
décideurs politiques disent une chose et
après ils se contredisent
ils disent une autre il ya des mesures
comprend pas très bien
par exemple en ce moment le premier
ministre portugais antonio poste doit
faire un musulman profil atik parce
qu'il a eu un contact avec un
collaborateur qui étaient infectés alors
qu'il est déjà il a déjà les deux doses
du vaccin depuis un mois alors les gens
se demandaient à quoi bon se faire
vacciner si il faut quand même 6 e ligne
ou pas il ya eu d expansion mais les
gens sont quand même fatigué de devoir
respecter toutes les consignes et
surtout la liberté des gens est plus
restreinte
est ce que vous êtes optimiste pour la
suite on sait qu'il ya des villes qui
ont été recompilé est-ce que vous pensez
que ça pourrait être le cas pour
lisbonne j'ai peint en ce moment il me
parle pas de confiner les gens mais s'il
continue à augmenter et les
épidémiologistes eux défendent que les
cats
on continue à augmenter en tout cas dans
les prochaines semaines ça ne
m'étonnerait pas que ça c'est à vous
garer merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci pour ce témoignage je
rappelle que vous êtes retraité en
informatique que vous vivez à côté un de
lisbonne au portugal ville qui donne
couvre-feu merci